كان ضحايا الكمين على
الحدود الأمريكية المكسيكية جميعًا أعضاء في
مجتمع المورمون الكبير الذي تعود جذوره في
شمال المكسيك إلى قرن من الزمان
، وينحدر معظمهم من مؤسس واحد ألما
داير
لوبارون ، نقل عائلته جنوب الحدود
ليعيش كمتعدد الزوجات في  القرن العشرين بعد
الولايات المتحدة  قام بتجريم ممارسة
الزواج التعددي
وتخلت عنه كنيسة المورمون السائدة في الأربعينيات من القرن
الماضي ، وبدأ في بناء Colonia LeBaron ما
سيصبح مستعمرة مترامية الأطراف في La
Mora Mexico تضم العديد من زوجاته
وأطفاله في المكسيك ، وأنشأت العائلة
فصيلًا جديدًا من المورمون يُدعى كنيسة
هو بكر امتلاء الأوقات ،
وهو أحد أبنائنا الأعشاب ،
بارون ، انفصل في النهاية عن الطائفة
ليشكل كنيسته الخاصة ، حمل الله
، أصبح هو وأتباعه سيئ السمعة في
سبعينيات القرن الماضي بعد أن اكتشف أن هيربل قد
قتل شقيقه جويل وربطته
لقتل العديد من الآخرين في الولايات
المتحدة والمكسيك ، تمت إدانته وتوفي لاحقًا
في سجن يوتا ، كان والد الأعشاب جويل
قد تولى منصب زعيم المستعمرة
قبل مقتله بعد
نهايته المروعة واستمر العديد من أطفال وأقارب جويل
في المستعمرة لمدة  عقود من الزمان
نما بهدوء في العمل في الغالب كمزارعين
وسلام نسبي ولكن عندما
بدأت الجريمة المنظمة في الازدهار في
المكسيك ليبيا  جعلتهم الثروة المقارنة
أهدافًا للابتزاز والاختطاف في عام
2009 ، أصبح حفيد جويل معروفًا
بمعارضته لعصابات المخدرات في المكسيك
وعمليات الاختطاف التي قاموا بها ، حيث رفض دفع
فدية قدرها مليون دولار عندما
تم اختطاف شقيقه الأصغر ودفع
المجتمع المحلي لاتخاذ موقف
ضد العنف على الرغم من
إطلاق سراح
شقيقه فيما بعد ، قُتل بنيامين لوبارون وزوج أخته
بعد فترة وجيزة
من جرهما من منزلهما للضرب
والإعدام الآن بعد عقد من
القتل على يد مهاجم معروف في
منطقة شابها العنف والإعدام.  تحكمها
عصابات المخدرات